we're going on a cruise all right we are
in our room this is nice sir movie
[Music]
good morning so today is day two of our
cruise adventures we're in Santa Barbara
now this is our morning view look at
this it's so pretty I love it so much
your hair looks crazy you don't need to
do your hair at sea we're sailors today
yeah
good aye aye captain
all right so we're all dressed and ready
to go and we're gonna go have our
breakfast and hopefully meet up with the
rest of the crew because we're on this
ship like we have very or service phone
service so none of us are really
communicating with each other so we're
just kind of seeing if we even run into
a pillar we took this trip it's a
company trip we're supposed to do some
team bonding for JK people right and we
thought you traffic won on the cruise
boat and so exactly why we wanted to do
a JK trip but we quickly found out
yesterday now it's not the case yeah
we're not really communicating in this
trip but a lot of us though were we are
like sticking together because there's
21 people on this trip so that's a lot
of people to try to keep together at all
time so everyone's just in their own
little separate cruise head cruise pun
intended yeah anyways we're gonna go eat
I'm getting weird let's go
[Music]
so pretty I didn't do this yesterday no
we thought were on the fifth floor like
whatever this is
okay okay how about this you go up the
staircase I'll be at the bottom the
staircase I'm Jack your rose yourselves
anytime let's do it I don't know what
the lines are hurt we suck at this
here's the third one
dude no I can't I can't be disrespectful
like that but I really want to touch it
Amy I think we touch it oh goodness play
anybody would've even on jazz playing I
don't touch it don't touch it whoa
they're loading are we gonna do that
later today yep so that's how they
learned people helped to coat ashore and
the Barbara
thank you so what happened so we went
into the Michelangelo day trying to get
more time so we got a ticket or thinking
that we're gonna get like that way we're
accidentally doing a show they're
loading so that's how I read people have
to go - or I'm laughing so hard I
accidentally cuz I hear the rest I guess
you're gonna eat and kind of imperfect
[Music]
did that laughing so far because we were
won by Randall whole tiny room looking
for the best table we didn't know we're
coming ashore I can get over it and we
started going down the stairs and we're
like wait where are they taking us
recruit this kind of nobody forces 100 I
think was the first because I think was
actually listening to the intercom oh
really but it was like I think we're
going to show her Marvin Lena's demeanor
yeah I would like yes it'd be kid
shyness
- I
I think about that just hits me like my
kid is gonna be nine years old next year
he's gonna be petted so weird
funny how kids have reversed shyness
like you're shy
they're like zero to five or six and
then once you get a little older you
have more awareness of everything around
you you get way more shy
[Music]
no no what you know I don't know we
didn't plan to be over here no we really
didn't plan to be right now we've got to
find somewhere to eat with the Elvis all
right any case where Santa Barbara
Barbara you still want to go to that one
spot we're looking for or anyone I go to
a different place now
oh no it's just gonna be all right
we're going with the Yelp Yelp
recommendation yep yep
instead of yep yo yo here's a random
thought how did they come out the name
Yelp what do they mean it's like when
you yelled like when you yelled like
you're yelping like a great thing all yo
yeah yo we decide to do a food and
restaurant reviews because you're
telling people you're reviewing it I
don't know I don't work for Yelp me
neither
[Music]
write it what you eat in there in tacos
with lemon
we're about to check out with Santa
Barbara's Mexican food tonight so far
they've been winning with the salsas the
one thing I'm really surprised about is
they actually have a peanut sauce I
never heard that before I had very low
expectations for peanut salsa for some
reason I mean just the way it sounds
peanut salsas you don't have high
expectations but it exceeded every
single bit of it - I got a platter do
sowait burritos look they don't give it
justice the flavors inside the burrito
is so good yet they on the outside this
is what a brutal looks like but on the
inside a burrito this is what a burrito
tastes like like - luckily Arunachal
establishes look so flavorful so
colorful so exciting that looks so
boring but on the inside that I
guarantee you it's gonna be so awesome
it's kind of like an egg roll hey girls
look so boring you're so Asian yeah so
right now we're thinking about maybe
going to little town called souvaine
[Music]
so we join the rest of the group we came
here but unexpectedly not knowing what
we're gonna do over here you just ended
join the rest of the crew no we're just
tagging along as you see what they're
gonna do is I don't you think you know
what you're gonna do exploring Santa
Barbara for the day
this is throwback Isaac this is Stretch
Armstrong it still stays on for flexible
Stretch Armstrong ladies and gentlemen
90s hey what are you doing at a toy
store yeah oh it's not what it looks
like let me just take a picture of this
it's called a Perplexus rookie oh don't
be a vision like that and we'll buy it
online for cheaper
[Applause]
thank you are cheaper cheaper cheaper
cheaper cheaper cheaper online online
Amazon Amazon amazon.com here is a good
old-fashioned toy store no you don't see
these anymore recently in the big city
you know it's all the iPads iPods am i a
handsome boy you may rely on it what
about me PC and I rarely get married
this year as I see it yet mmm is you're
gonna start planning right let's do it
we haven't started climbing maybe next
year
it is decidedly so oh I was kind of
hoping for a no because I'm already well
I meant to dominate team oh well we have
a baby in 2000 easy signs point to yes
oh I said yes again let me see well we
have a baby 2016 and see if it's flying
you they rely on it why liar baby I'm
buying it
oh my god - vocals with many color
pencils but there's hope
what is wrong with me why do I freak out
with many things but this is how you
like what you do in Santa Barbara the
choice to get their vernacular money
fight is binocular p.m. alright so we
just visited 90s nostalgia a toy store
on to the 2016 toy store of me at the
carnival
welcome to get our hands on this is a
real toy store it's our choice card
here's our section nerds I walked over
here you guys are I was peeking out over
these political sliders sliders Gamble's
in a Gimbels we went from one nerd
storage to the next are you saying that
you're not a nerd I'm not a nerd I'm
just a child at heart so that nerd
nutter
yeah I'd like first to for the first two
doors this door I don't care and it's
gonna belt this dog you're only in the
business of making videos now though I'm
not the one making videos
you know one into Carnival a crew
members can always turn the camera on
themselves and walk away
adios I don't know if I remember being
is agent explained with the Popular's
indoors two hoops posed by me
yeah feel like there was something like
right up foot it's like yeah it's like
it looks like so like zooming in
something like like oh my Chris good
night gopher look so fun
he said when we shoot Go Go Pro did
never look that fun all away for the
reveal
[Music]
I'm sure you got a whole new look for
yourself
and you should you know what though I
don't care cuz I am spoiling myself just
tomorrow's my birthday this is my
birthday present to myself look there's
our home but first we're gonna eat and
then we're gonna go back home lamb
chowder ladies and gentlemen I think
it's just clam chowder it's the most
simplest be food Steudle everybody is
not crazy it's delicious
[Applause]
feeling i right
good I think it's pretty good
ah no sir
you can do it do your boogers use just
as it tastes way better than your
boogers I can guarantee you that
all right so by some miracle be
convinced I stood to try some oysters
here we go and I look sandwich
you got it
oh yeah Faison was alive are the lemon
for your tea
I prefer are you doing pick up on that
one yeah it's a monkey pose relieving in
Santa Barbara going back to the truth oh
yeah then once I get back we're going
and we're still up for it
swimmin Jacuzzi full sweater Timmy oh
cool jacuzzi cool okay a good day of
exploration all right you ready to swim
buddy I'm laid out for 5 sec
[Music]
I call this a really really cool oh I
was supposed to join it with a jacuzzi
and I didn't know doing that
I'm just chillin here and then drinking
my lotto
[Music]
[Music]
20:27 that's so crazy
Cheers say mommy he was drinking up all
the champagne I gotta catch up to
collection